and a wine to welcome to see do playing
Cowell 0 and he was black and turn and
trying to slide again okay yeah this is
actually what I don't like it okay it it
was bound to happen at some point can
also take within my it yeah this ending
is supposed to be okay for black even
though it doesn't look like lots of fun
and ending is wrong is the wrong term I
mean it's not an endgame strictly
speaking what's now look at the age
maybe create seven I think I'll just
cancel at least there's some imbalances
here with the pawn structure was a quick
decision is it that obvious that this is
strong maybe they're so
f-for what's the deal here right before
i go f6 that's so bad or here six and
maybe it is bad I know but at least it's
interesting now it's not a lame position
okay rook e8 Jack I should have seen
that move I didn't I absolutely did not
think about this it's not exactly rocket
science check okay
wondering if he goes he's 6 wouldn't be
sure this is so great to be honest no he
wants to kill me this is a this is now
blatantly obvious okay he just wants to
totally kill me okay register I just
want to trade stuff wow wow okay now
take
hey this is very questionable what why
did Jim objectively it doesn't have
enough for the porn here it's slightly
murky and some of my pawns a week of
course Angie 65 and so on so it is some
compensation but probably probably not
enough ok I can trade it all ready now
one of three light c5 at the end I
wonder Jack okay let's do it anyway you
can take f2 and this was my idea oh wow
so he just place the endgame upon down
okay maybe 95 is so awkward here that's
possible that it comes to e6e mm-hmm
need to get my night midnight into the
game 97 and so on
check ok is kini for maybe so screw up
check check
jenny didn't see this coming absolutely
didn't oh my god check check check I
have no way to cover that bloody porn
without giving giving up lots of stuff
damn I absolutely hate to draw this game
after the way it went
cackling no not playing for win I don't
see a way to avoid it only something
totally ridiculous
maybe I can do that it is totally
ridiculous gems but ICS didn't see that
this hangs oh my god I'm doing
everything to lose this game this is
really great check this is specially
great after white was so so clearly
playing for lost year with his strategy
check check
time warning there's no way to stop that
bloody porn and check 9 f6 is got 95 in
I should have just taken the damned
Roger yeah I to keep doing this mistake
I keep making this mistake I really do
check when I'm not satisfied with the
with the draw that added just display
something that loses and because I want
to win be no because of the way the game
was earlier when when white was just
playing for loss the whole way is but it
changed that the situation has changed
and you just have to accept the draw
than and sometimes of course I could
resign but I don't want to check really
hate to resign check as long as you have
a night you don't resign old Larry
Christian Christians rule check
j he's not exactly playing this well but
ok it's it's it's a queen it's a queen
of course check check check check maybe
I can always hope for a stalemate check
I wonder what NT otherwise taking so
long maybe cuz he's asking himself why
when I'm playing this playing this on
what the hell I should just take the
draw sometimes yeah absolutely hate you
can see drawers after check option stuff
like f5 is played you know he just gives
away your porn and gets into a bad
position pretty yeah just like that
check but still the ending here is
nothing i can probably what what can I
do better here so Queens you five wins
because route 28 counts okay now anyway
but still here also edge i'm just a pawn
up I'm really just a pawn up Kingi seven
and it's that better yeah the night gets
gets very active so it probably isn't
that much but it's still I mean it's
impossible to lose this position check
and check unless you don't take the draw
of caution what what did I do wrong I
mean this is this is a night and give a
porn up Knight f6 may be immediately
check and this is already a problem this
night is so active
I should i do something this is this is
right i mean i'm really sure about that
but the next couple of moves here my
engine wants to do this check then I
have some witty insurances but it's not
go to clear way okay i justjust i should
just keep your eye I just can't too
classy drawers check and check times I
just play stuff that you do this which
is switches oculus and I keep doing that
check I just I just by the way I just
blundered this g6 bond if I go here's
can still continue the game I just
blundered this in one move it was really
really terrible and here jack the ending
is just lost yeah it's just a bad game
okay thanks for watching